[Musique]
c'est une formulation de terre qu'on va
stabiliser avec du ciment la btc va
faire des l'inertie thermique donc une
capacité d'accumulation de la chaleur
donc elle n'empêche la chaleur des
pénétrer à l'intérieur du bâtiment c'est
ça l'intérêt de la btc par rapport à un
matériau ciment qui lui accumule mais
n'empêche pas de pénétrer c'est à dire
il nous envoie tout de suite à chaleur
le sénégalais moyen
son but est de construire le moins cher
possible et que ce sera vite construit
on va dire donc qu'il va prendre la
solution la plus proche de lui et ce
qu'il voit tout le temps c'est du béton
donc il va même pas se poser la question
d'un autre matériau
[Musique]
ça a été conçu pour ne pas recevoir des
climatisations d'où la ventilation
naturelle d'une inertie thermique tout
ce qu on dit aujourd'hui par un toro au
changement climatique
à dégradation de l'environnement oui ce
matériau ou les matériaux la utilisés
peuvent être la solution pour certains
problèmes ils font pas peut-être régler
tous les problèmes du monde mais pour
contribuer quoi
[Musique]